[Musica]
quanti hanno pianto oggi
quanti almeno una volta questa settimana
che allora a giudicare dalle poche mani
alzate
sono due le possibilità o viviamo nel
migliore dei mondi possibili e io sono
l'unica che non se n'è accorta
oppure siamo davanti alla più classica
delle reticenze
perché nel 2022 piangere è ancora un
problema ora io vi chiedo scusa per
l'argomento mi rendo conto il pianto non
fa ridere non è divertente e lo so sto
deludendo le vostre aspettative però non
me lo dite perché altrimenti mi viene
una gran voglia di piangere
certo adesso non è che dovete a ridere
per forza perché altrimenti pensate che
io pianga per il fatto che non vi ho
fatto ridere abbastanza neanche dovete
piangere perché non vi fa ridere il
fatto che io piango e ci siamo capiti
allora con voi voglio parlare del pianto
ma non di quello fisiologico quello per
cui l'occhio reagisce a un aggressione
esterna che ne so un pulviscolo un colpo
di vento la linea della cipolla
l'importo dell'ultima bolletta della
luce
no voglio che a parlare del pianto e
motivo cioè di quella voglia di piangere
che arriva così quando meno te l'aspetti
come il vigile urbano
solo che il vigile urbano lo mandi via
con 36 euro
la voglia di piangere no quella ti
rimane qua ti strozza la gola è l'unico
modo che hai per toglier tela e piangere
però viviamo in una società dove il
pianto o viene strumentalizzato i
palinsesti televisivi lo dimostrano
ampiamente
oppure viene deriso denigrato bandito in
quanto segno di fragilità emotiva
io ho iniziato a piangere appena nata
come tutti noi del resto
piangere è la prima cosa che facciamo
quando veniamo al mondo
piangere è il nostro modo di dire al
mondo che siamo vivi e il nostro modo di
comunicare
ci spaventano le prime funzioni
fisiologiche e allora piangiamo vogliamo
attirare l'attenzione della mamma
e allora piangiamo dobbiamo soddisfare
un bisogno primario e allora piangiamo
e allora io non capisco perché se il
pianto è così naturale ci colpisce
non capisco perché quando un neonato
piange
anziché prenderlo in braccio
cullarlo
allattarlo cambiarlo noi no
noi ci avviciniamo alla culla e con
quella voce idiota che fa accapponare la
pelle gli chiediamo perché piangi
ma io dico ma che domanda è ma un
neonato come ti deve rispondere è appena
nata lo dice anche la parola neonato
cosa deve fare una conferenza stampa
il dipartimento di informatica e
ingegneria del muroran institute
dell'isola di hokkaido sta mettendo a
punto un apparecchietto per riuscire a
codificare i primi vagiti dei neonati
però questi scienziati
hanno interrotto l'esperimento perché
hanno dichiarato di essere davanti a un
serio problema giuro è tutto vero hanno
detto che loro riescono a rilevare il
pianto riescono a tradurlo ma attenzione
dichiarazione vera
non riescono ad avere la conferma
verbale da parte del neonato spesso
sulla veridicità della traduzione no ma
dico ma siete dei geni
ma del jen ma veramente
allora io capisco se non c'è il lavoro
te lo devi inventare però così mi sembra
un po eccessivo ma io mi immagino il
povero neonato nella culla disperato per
ore questi ricercatori intorno con tutti
i loro apparecchietti il neonato alla
fine esasperato si alza glielo dice
signore allora sono appena nato mi son
pisciato addosso esigue essere cambiato
adesso per cortesia cinque minuti e poi
fuori che ora della nanna no
eppure
eppure fino a che siamo nel reparto
maternità
possiamo dire di essere in un'isola
felice certo se non siamo ad hokkaido
ovvio
nel reparto maternità noi possiamo
piangere tutti insieme senza vergogna
maschi e femmine
però
appena usciamo dal reparto maternità il
gioco si fa duro i duri non possono
piangere a pagarne le maggiori
conseguenze sono i maschietti per loro
la parola d'ordine non piangere e
vengono così educati sin dalla più
tenera età con regole ferree
1 piangere per un futile motivo verrà
considerato capriccio pertanto seguirà
scappellotto e frase di norma almeno
piangi per qualcosa
2 piangere per rifiuto di minestrina
verrà considerato vizio pertanto seguirà
scappellotto e frase di norma pesa
quelli che non ha niente da mangiare
tre piangere davanti ai propri amici per
un torto subito verrà considerato
debolezza
pertanto seguirà scappellotto e frase di
norma cosa sei una femminuccia
4 piangere davanti alla propria
fidanzata dichiarando che con l'altra è
stato solo sesso
verrà considerato altissimo tradimento
pertanto seguirà scappellotto e frase di
norma brutto porco verme schifoso infame
torna da tua madre
piangere tornando dalla propria madre
verrà considerato fallimento
pertanto seguirà scappellotto e frase di
norma se tutto tuo padre
così facendo capite che per gli uomini è
difficile crescono inibendo le loro
emozioni
aggravando così gli stereotipi di genere
e le relazioni invece cosa succede a noi
donne per noi donne il pianto è più
tollerato
forse perché si pensa che geneticamente
siamo dotati di maggiore sensibilità
cosa che io potrei smentire benissimo
presentandovi mia suocera
oppure pensando a una donna a capo di un
partito politico italiano un francese e
scegliete voi ma se avete scelto non me
lo dite se noi inizia a piangere adesso
finisco domani mattina
degli studiosi dicono che la donna
piange il 40 per cento più degli uomini
perché produce prolattina dei
ricercatori olandesi sostengono che sia
proprio questa maggiore produzione di
prolattina che fa sì che la donna possa
piangere per ben quindici minuti di fila
contro i 5 minuti degli uomini io vorrei
dire ricercatori olandesi che non è
l'unico caso in cui l'uomo dura di meno
comunque io non so se sia la prolattina
o no io piango per tutto e ho fatto di
tutto per risolvere questo problema
perché mi hanno sempre detto che questo
era un problema così sono andata a fare
corsi di autostima
voi direte chi sono quei cretini che
fanno i corsi di autostima io
funzionano è perché io uscivo e dicevo
piango benissimo
sulla migliore come piange io non piango
nessuno così quindi per l'autostima
funzionano per il pianto no
poi mi hanno detto che ero egoriferita e
che per smettere di piangere dovevo
pensare a chi stava peggio di me mi
dicevano pensa a chi non ha una casa
pensa a chi non ha un lavoro
pensa a chi non ha un amore
ci pensi
e giù a piangere poi
poi ho provato a fare danza yoga
addirittura box perché mi avevano detto
che sfogando l'aggressività la voglia di
piangere sarebbe diminuita invece no io
uscivo con due occhi così perché mi
asciugava le lacrime con i guantoni
l'unica cosa che sembrava funzionare
era la psicoterapia perché io andavo
parlavo il nodo alla gola si scioglieva
la voglia di piangere diminuiva e lo
psicoterapeuta mi diceva brava signorina
lei finalmente sta acquisendo un
pensiero positivo
io dicevo grazie
solo che poi quando gli lasciavo 120
euro mi ritornava una gran voglia di
piangere il problema è dove vai a
piangere perché io vivo a milano
milano e la citta dell'indifferenza cioè
a milano secca di per terra o se in area
di rigore a san siro
oranti questi dra nessuno eppure in una
città come milano il pianto non passa
inosservato appena ti scendono due
lacrime boom hai tutti gli occhi addosso
voi non sapete come io abbia desiderato
un posto per piangere tutto mio
intimo
certo mi sarebbe piaciuto che ne so
piangere davanti a una finestra
affacciata al davanzale
magari con sotto la senna che scorre
io le mie belle calze parigine
le foglie d'autunno che cadono come in
una poesia di prévert
sottofondo la musica di jacques brel
due lacrime che mi sfiora nel viso e una
mano che mi sfiora la spalla che mi dice
un amore
certo sarebbe così se vivesse in un film
di truffaut
e invece io vivo in un condominio di
periferia o una finestra ma non la posso
aprire perché quella del piano di sopra
mi butta in testa le briciole le
parigine non le posso mettere perché mi
stringono mi fanno venire i salami la
musica di sottofondo non è certo quella
di jacques brel medi quel cretino del
mio vicino che sta imparando per elisa e
tutti i pomeriggi ton
anatemi voglia di sfondare il muro e di
orlando quella nota lì è un do
l'unica cosa di francese che ho e nel
frigo il brie
e ogni volta che piango si arriva
qualcuno ma non mi dice
mi sfiora la spalla
e mi dice perché piangi
e di nuovo torna questa fastidiosa
domanda io non lo so come ti devo
rispondere io non lo so perché piango in
piango per tutto piango perché sono
felice perché sono triste perché sono
depressa perché non sono alta 180 perché
non so fare la spesa perché non so se
nella lavastoviglie le forchette si
mettono con la punta di sun con la punta
giu piango perché mia nonna tutti i
pomeriggi legge necrologi arriva e dice
ai suoi morto il panettiere lo so nonna
mi dispiace piango perché ho dimenticato
le chiavi di casa piango perché un bel
dritto il maglione bianco perché sto
guardando dirty dancing e proprio quando
lui dice nessuno può mettere baby in un
angolo arriva la nonna dice ma lo sai
che è morto pure lui lo so no no mi
dispiace
piango perché mi scrive il mio padre
piango perché no mi telefona mia madre
bianco perché mi si impalla il computer
perché è uscito un nuovo dpcm piango
perché dal ted non si può uscire da
questo tappetino rosso cosa succede se
esci dal tappo vino rosso bianco e vero
cosa succede non lo so io piango perché
perché tutti i giorni guardo la tele
muoiano milioni e milioni di persone mia
nonna è ancora viva io piango perché non
so perche piango ecco l'ho detto a me
piacerebbe essere una di quelle donne
forti storiche quelle donne che
oggi ho una gran voglia di piangere ma
non lo farò
perché sei orgogliosa
no perché sono truccate
oppure mi piacerebbe essere una di
quelle donne organizzate quelle che
riescono a programmarsi il tempo per
piangere
allora dunque oggi ho una gran voglia di
piangere allora vediamo le dure meeting
alle tre premi storming alle 4 lo
shooting va bene facciamo così che oggi
tra le cinque di 55 crying
ma le mie preferite
le mie preferite sono le seduttive
quelle che cosa fai
piangi
no sono due gocce di chanel
a volte penso
come sarebbe diverso se ci insegnassero
fin da piccoli che piangere non è un
problema
gli antichi dicevano che si piange
perché il cuore si scalda e il vapore
acqueo arriva fino agli occhi
per gli antichi la fragilità non era un
difetto
era una virtù
e noi se ci dimentichiamo di essere
fragili
mettiamo a rischio la nostra esistenza
le nostre relazioni
allora io penso che la domanda perché
piangi sia sbagliata e che dovremo
guardarci intorno e pour ce n'è un'altra
necessaria la vostra vita che è
perché non piangi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì